men working high risk jobs women tend to
steer away from the stem fields that are
science men are the majority of
workplace deaths so if you're more if
it's a more dangerous job you're going
to get paid more
even they did a study on Uber and Uber
drivers make the same money this is how
you work but because men drive faster
they make more money than women would
you say they're more agreeable or do you
think that's just how a lot of us just
see women to be more because your mom I
feel like personally I'm more nervous to
ask I don't have like just a Mana
question than a woman I feel like it's
more I don't know like I wouldn't yeah I
wouldn't yeah like if you're lost you're
not gonna more time you're not gonna go
to a man if you're lost for directions
you'd usually go to a woman it's
agreeable yeah and it's like if I don't
think they're naturally more agreeable I
think we are because historically we had
to raise children like there's
biological reasons the way we feel the
way we feel like when I went around the
room asked them if they'd wife a girl
that did only fans the reason they're
saying no is because historically they
had to ensure paternity